today on Sam an eco channel Ren teaches
Carmichael how to use a boosted board
without dying
[Music]
the texted me a picture of LARP swords
web sword is a fake sword that used to
take your friends Snyder
whoa not even hitting me too hard that
man top of the nosh whatever where the
birds come out and fly on my tab two
three times fold your thumb no you take
full yeah nine seven thousand layers and
foam folded folded Damascus phone this
is really cool hey Nick so the one-wheel
yes is my favorite thing that I have but
my first love is the boosted board
Oh Michaels like man I want to get some
more moving shots while you're on the
one wheel what if I learn how to ride
the boosting board so I was like you
know what you're right so I brought it
to work we're gonna go have a bit of a
session and hopefully Carmichael doesn't
die pass smooth is right
mr. often like level one mode which is
like really baby mode two is pretty good
three you're getting up there towards be
pretty probe but we're gonna start you
on level four what guys we're gonna go
so advanced my special Luigi helmet
although the top is like falling off
only red you did it I'm goofy which
means your right foot is in front as
opposed to your left foot being in front
so you're very goofy dude green it's
actually a really flexible board I can
bounce the ground yeah this bamboo so it
flexes really easily if you floor it and
it flies out from under you and you fall
on your ass hand this off to you
Carmichael yeah that's on the that's on
the highest level right now do you think
you're gonna fall I don't want to
sprained my wrist ready in three two one
back when we first moved into this
building there's a man that lives across
the street and he owned all these
buildings he let us set up our music
instruments in one of his warehouses the
thing is we had to sell all of them
because he was losing lots of money
every month along with those warehouses
being sold there goes our practice space
and no longer had a place to put my drum
set
now drums are super super loud they do
not work very well in an apartment
building style structure so unlike Sam
here who plays the piano and guitar I
had no way to practice the drums and now
for the past four years I have not been
able to play the drums
kind of sucks until now until now he's
just got a new set of a thumbs
I research actually for about the past
two years trying to find the perfect
electronic drum set I saved and I waited
my research and I save I find about this
so rollin TD 25kv
and it took me about three hours to
build last night and now I can finally
sit down to play it but main advantage
this over a real drum set is that it's
much quieter all I do is I put on
headphones
it sounds like real drums to me but
everybody else just here is G is sending
me a text saying hey you're supposed to
be over ten minutes to go to film an old
episode before I can play this I have to
go fill in old episode but then I'm
going to come back I'm gonna play for
the rest of the night it's gonna be
great can't wait I'm opening so we're
recording land party we're doing sword
fighting I took very careful you had
gloves on everything and D just nailed
me right between these two fingers all
right your left hand just skip you get
right into digging you've got Luke
Skywalker's dad I can't straighten my
fingers without it hurting it's not
makeup that's real you know the drum
said I just made tried playing it and it
hurts really bad I can't believe my
drumset ah
there you go thread it nice nice you're
going going well doing good just keep
going
[Music]
how fast am I going like five miles an
hour really it feels like I'm going 20
you're definitely not going 20
I'm just waving to drivers who are
politely patient with me as I get out of
their way
uh-huh
something I'm noticing is the more I'm
going forward whether this way that way
I need to be leaning to counter and put
my strength
forward and then if I'm going to be
slowing down I need to start doing the
opposite because I'm going the other way
your pronoun
[Music]
you